call your friends you love the ones who
you know that if you call them at three
o'clock in the morning they would answer
the phone do not do this with family it
doesn't work those relationships are too
close do it with the friends you love
and ask them the simple question why are
we friends and they're going to look at
you like you're crazy because the part
of the brain that controls feelings and
behavior doesn't control language
ironically you stop asking the question
why because the question why is an
emotional question and it elicits
emotional responses after your friends
say I don't why are you asking me this
you switch to what questions what
specifically is it about me that I know
that you would be there for me no matter
what and it's going to be very difficult
for them and they're going to struggle
don't help them don't let anybody else
help them you have to let them go
through the uncomfortable process and
you have to play Devil's Advocate so
they'll say things like I don't know
you're funny you're smart I can rely on
you and you say good that's the
definition of a friend you have that
with all your friends what specifically
is it about me that I know you would be
there for me no matter what you're going
to keep at them and eventually they'll
give up and they'll stop describing you
and they'll start describing themselves
and this is what my friend said to me
they said I don't know Simon all I know
is that I can just sit in a room with
you I don't even have to talk to you and
I feel inspired and I got goosebumps so
what they did is they articulated my
value in their lives and I had an
emotional response so you'll get to the
point where they'll say something that
you will either get goosebumps or you're
well up with tears or something will
happen you will have an emotional
response you won't get the exact words
of your why but you will get in the
ballpark what you'll find is if you do
it with multiple friends you'll get very
similar if not the exact same answer
because the value you have in their
lives is the same it's you so it's a fun
way to find your why need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
quit on my business partner I was making
300 bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from one of the best Simon sinek and my
take on this top 10 rules of success
enjoy
rule number two do good while doing well
I think people make
they create a dichotomy a false
dichotomy that they have to either
choose service or individual success
right that those two are somehow
mutually exclusive and that service
means uh living a a life of suffering
which is nonsense
um and and then you hear these silly
these silly uh um sort of uh uh
projections like I'm gonna do well so
that I can do good so I'm gonna put
myself first
and then eventually I'll do good for
others you know a friend of mine who is
a a philanthropist someone came to him
for advice on philanthropy and this was
a former CEO of a very large company and
um and my friend asked him so what what
are you most proud of in your
philanthropy and he said well you know
we started this charity in the inner
city where we help kids go on to college
and he said that's amazing you know how
many kids have you helped he said 15 he
says is that the proudest thing you've
done you know in your life he says yeah
I'm really proud
and my friend said so let me understand
this you're proud of 15 kids you helped
go to college meanwhile you destroyed
the lives of the 60 000 people who
worked for you
you know
um uh like that's that's what happens
when you uh do well so that you can do
good you put yourself at the center of
the equation and then eventually you'll
try and even the the scale so you can
feel good before you die
um
um and the uh and and the reality is the
opposite is true do well uh sorry do
good and you can also do well right
um but doing good should not be
something that we save for our
retirement
um doing good is something that we can
do every day and and and and and it's
remarkably easy I mean what your
neighbor did for you just by looking out
his window was good saying hello asking
somebody how are you and actually caring
about the answer saying please and thank
you you know I mean these are very very
little things that cost nothing that
make other people
um feel like you saw them that they
matter that they're that they exist
um and that that is that is a that is
all steps we take to to doing good and
of course it can it can it can grow from
there it can scale from there rule
number three share your art to me
um art is like a gift you know if you
have capacity if you have talent if you
have grit and hard work and you want to
produce gifts are supposed to be given
so what's the point of giving a gift is
no one gets it
right
um what's the point of producing a
symphony if no one gets to hear it
um so I think reception is important to
to give the art point
meaning as opposed to point less you
know otherwise you're just decorating
your home
now we could have a debate whether I'm
receiving it myself
right
um so we could definitely debate that
but but I I I I uh I think I think and
maybe this is just the Romantic in me
um it has to be enjoyed and and maybe
one one one person is fine maybe if you
hang it in your own home and it's just
for you that's fine too but uh but I
think art has to be enjoyed otherwise
what's the point you know
um
um otherwise it's just therapy you know
I'm just painting for therapy and we all
do things like that you know
[Music]
um
I already has to have another human
being involved oh to me art is about a
relationship right you you can't call
yourself a romantic or somebody who
chooses to to love another if if nobody
ever feels Your Love
you know uh it's I think I think art is
um is a is is it's a type of language
right
um I know uh people who are the world's
worst communicators when it comes to
their emotions when you ask when you
have a conversation with them I've dated
some of them
um but given the opportunity to write
it's magical
and the feelings pour out on a page in
an eloquence like I've never seen and as
everyone here knows great art in some
way shape or form is always personal or
semi-autobiographical right it's too
hard to write pure fiction you know we
in we we put ourselves in it because it
gives it a sense of reality and it's
what makes us passionate for the subject
that we're tackling
um I know dancers who you know you meet
them and they're like this but as soon
as they start dancing you realize
there's it's all there so so art is
language and if no one hears you you
know there's a tree if a tree falls in
the woods you know if no one hears what
you're saying is it worth saying
anything they're just thoughts
so what's the point of writing a play
that never gets shown it's just a
thought you know it's just an intention
so yeah no I think it must be shared
it's it's the it's it's one of the ways
in which people communicate rule number
four show your potential what if our why
scares us
um and and we fear that people won't see
it do we abandon it or do we just go for
it okay so there's two thoughts there
that are worth unpacking okay if other
people don't see it okay that's let's
let's deal with that first because I
think that's a little that's a little
simpler
um if other people don't see it then the
question is are we showing it right and
so many of us all of us especially at
various times
we're all lying hiding and faking at
various points right
um somebody asks a question you know
that makes us uncomfortable in a public
forum sometimes we agree to something we
say yes even though it's not true
because we just don't want to embarrass
ourselves we're very often inauthentic
plus we live in an Instagram Facebook
talkable world we're all presenting
ourselves and curating ourselves as how
we want to be so we're really good at
showing people the kind of person we
want to be it's kind of ironic as well
if you think about relationships
um you know we present ourselves as the
as our best selves but it's only really
when our vulnerabilities and
insecurities are revealed can love exist
um that's that magical authenticity so I
would argue that if if the world doesn't
see who you are you know are there ways
that you can share it with the world in
a way that is inspiring um to them and
and authentic to you
um uh how you show up you know uh
sometimes the clothes you wear sometimes
it's silly stuff
um you know I I always I would often
wear bright brightly colored ties in
college I know a little a little nerdy
but
um one because it sort of was a
reflection of my Independence I didn't
dress like everyone else but I it also
made people smile I would catch them
seeing my my tie and it would make them
smile and and I liked that
um and so there are lots of little
things we can do personally
um to bring our y to life now what I'm
really interested is what you said
Andrea when you said what if our why
scares us now if it's actually scary
because it's dangerous or difficult
um then maybe it's not fully Roi if it
scares us but because we are afraid that
others will judge us for what it is like
this is truly who I am this is why I
wake up out of bed every morning you
know then then I think you have to go
for it now the question is do you have
to jump in the deep end I think that's a
question of your own risk tolerance I
think there's nothing wrong with wading
into the water starting in the shallow
end
um I mean think about it look what I do
for a living inspire people that do the
things that Inspire them like how corny
and cheesy is that right like I'm fully
aware of that when I've first started
talking about it people were like well
that's cheesy I'm like I know I know and
so I I but I still would do it and was
it a jumping in the deep end no I would
dip my toe and I would test things out
you know and I would try things out not
see how it was received and sometimes it
went well and sometimes it didn't go
well I was learning to swim with my why
as basically was my why floaties I was
wearing y floaties that's what I was
doing
um so yeah I think if it's if you if it
feels right because that's the test of a
why you know does it feel right does it
feel like who I am does it give you
chills or Goosebumps or does it make you
well up when you think about it does it
excite you uh then it's probably
accurate and yeah then you're gonna have
to at least get in the shallow end you
dip your foot in and try try using it at
certain places and as you get more
comfortable you'll learn to swim also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out R3 favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five enact good values
so my favorite definition of culture is
culture equals values plus Behavior
um and so you have to have a clear set
of values first and Innovation honesty
you know these aren't values those are
the things we write on the wall but
those are nouns and if it's values plus
Behavior it's things we want people to
do everybody thinks they're honest yet
everybody tells lies
so the value isn't be honest the value
or honesty the value is tell the truth
the value is an innovation you can't
walk into someone's office and say a
little more Innovation today please
right you know uh doesn't like nobody
you can't innovate you can't execute on
Innovation it's not an instruction
um but you can tell people look at the
problem from a different angle like
that's something you can do so to to and
and by the way your values are not
aspirational they're not a bunch of
Executives sitting at an off-site
cutting pictures out of magazines and
saying this is the company we want to be
your values are who you are when you are
at your natural best
your culture already exists but you're
not necessarily always operating at your
natural best and that's as true for
companies as it is as it is for
individuals
so to uncover your values is not
aspirational it's a process of discovery
and then you can write down this I've
never seen more than five weirdly don't
understand the biology but when you
start getting more than five they start
to overlap enough that you could
probably eliminate one of them which I
think is interesting
um but there's there's at least uh sorry
this is uh at most five values three to
five
um that are who you are when you operate
at your natural best
and now the question is is can you
develop
recognition rewards incentives to
promote those values are you talking
about those values are you hiring to
those values are you firing people who
may be high performers but refuse to
live to those values because then what
you're doing is reinforcing to the rest
of the company that the values matter
more than anything else
which is really important because if we
talk about values but then all we do is
promote toxic team members who are high
performers and we've all had this happen
where sometimes even management knows
you're like you know that person is a
real they're like I know but
their numbers are so good right
um and then we let them be and so that
sends a message to the rest of the
company that we're talking about these
values but we don't actually believe it
um and so you don't necessarily have to
fire the person but we do have to coach
that person well number six seek
opportunities when my career was just
getting going
uh and I was a speaker
uh which by the way was not my chosen
career I fell into it
um uh there is a I forgotten the name of
the organization I think it's called The
Meeting Planners Association of America
something like that where basically all
the people from all the corporations and
conferences who hire the speakers like
that's their job they have their own
conference
and so to get invited to this thing is
like
it's like American Idol like yeah like
if you do well you get a career for the
rest of your life because everyone in
the room will want to hire you for their
conferences for the rest of years and if
you if you bomb they all know who you
are and you will have no career right
like that's um
I've done this a bunch now I'm you know
I'm relaxed on stage now you know I got
this you know and like this is one of
those events that makes every speaker
nervous and uh
and it's in this cavernous Place
ironically it's like the worst venue it
was like it echoed so you'd stand on the
stage talking you could hear yourself
anyway during my talk I'm doing start
with Y is back in the early days I got
this you know done this a million times
and don't know what happened I lost my
train of thought
okay I I know this I've been through
this from before so I went quiet
you usually find my place and then I
pick up again like I know how to do this
I've lost my train of thought before I
went quiet
and nothing happened like nothing came
into my mind I had nothing
and now I panicked
and as soon as the Panic sets in now now
all rational thought disappears and now
I start sweating and my heart starts
pounding and I got nothing I got nothing
and I look at my pad and I look at the
audience and I look at my pad and I look
at the audience
and then I turn to them and say
have you ever had that feeling where you
forget what you're talking about
and everything collapses your hearts and
your stomach your heart's pounding you
start sweating your hands get clammy and
sheer panic and they're all smiling I go
I said I'm having that right now
oh I said I said and I gotta tell you it
feels fantastic
I said because I do this so much
sometimes I forget to be present and I
said right now I feel completely alive I
said I feel totally present and totally
with this it's as much as I is as crazy
it is this is amazing
I said okay I need someone's help can
somebody please tell me what I was just
talking about because I do not know what
I was talking about and they all erupted
in Applause
I got more Applause for that
than
for the actual speech
but the point is the point is
is that in every so in every cloud there
is a silver lining in everything that
happens to us there is goodness rule
number seven aim to be a leader a U.S
marine told me the first Criterion for
being a leader is you have to want to be
one
um and if you look at the way the
Marines select their leaders select
their officers it's a it's different
than than with their enlisted core so if
you enlist in the Marine Corps you go to
Paris Island in the East or you go to
San Diego in the west to to boot camp
and they will make you into a marine
yeah that's what it says we make Marines
yeah and uh if you change your mind
you're gonna be in the Marine Corps
whether you like it or not there is no
changing your mind yeah once you sign on
the dotted line you're in yeah in the
office of core it's different if you
want to be an officer in the Marine
Corps you go to OCS and Quantico
Virginia
and uh uh it's a 10-week training
and uh you only have to stay in the
first four weeks
uh for the next six weeks you can drop
out at any time for any reason yeah
um and the reason is is because if you
don't want to be a leader they don't
want you yeah they give you the choice
um you know leadership to me is like is
like is like being a parent everybody
has the capacity to be a parent doesn't
mean everybody wants to be a parent and
everybody should be a parent right
leadership is the same everybody has the
capacity yeah it doesn't mean everybody
wants it and doesn't mean everybody
should it comes a great personal
sacrifice it means you have to
constantly worry about other people like
being a parent yeah
um you have to uh love them whether you
chose them or not yeah you know yeah uh
your team uh and and there are skills to
being a parent and everyone who's ever
had a child starts reading books when
they find out that they're pregnant for
the first time you know uh they start
asking their friends they start asking
their parents for advice and it's
constant you know whether the kid's
struggling at school or struggling at
home or having a good time this it's all
the things like I I hate hanging out
with my sister and my brother-in-law
when they're with their their other
friends who have families because all
they talk about is kids yeah right
um uh well leadership's the same yeah
leadership's the same you know the the
great leaders that I know or are all
students of leadership they're obsessed
they're constantly talking about it
they're reading books about it they're
watching talks about it they're reading
articles about it they get together they
it's it's the topic of conversation sure
um and so you know if you want to learn
the skill set I mean number one you have
to want to do it
um and B you're gonna have to do some
work yeah I mean it takes it takes
effort rule number eight learn to spark
motivation I don't think you can
motivate the unmotivated I I don't think
you could motivate people people either
are motivated or unmotivated I think you
can inspire people
um and uh and you know you can motivate
people with sticks and carrots you know
offer them Bounty or threatened
punishment and you'll get behavior that
you want
is there loyalty is their love
absolutely not
um usually when people are unmotivated
it's not necessarily them it might be
the situation they're in
um maybe they don't belong in the
culture
um maybe they feel unseen or unheard
maybe they're scared maybe they're
unprepared so we we have to you know
when somebody's unmotivated let's not
label them as unmotivated first what are
the 20 other things that it could also
be let's start there now are there some
people in the world who are made
unmotivated absolutely you hired them
which means you bear some responsibility
if it's if it's time to transition them
to help them find another place where
they're going to be a better fit we
can't yell at them and call them stupid
and motivated and push them out the door
we have to bear some of the
responsibility we hired them and if we
made a mistake and hired somebody who's
a bad cultural fit then we have to take
care of them and help them transition to
somewhere where they're going to be a
better fit
um I think that um you know if we only
focus on motivating people and that's a
factor then um you're only going to get
very finite thinking an excessive amount
of motivating things like hit this
number get this bonus uh you'll get a
motivated employee pool that doesn't
care about about each other might stab
each other in the back and eventually
will take a better job somewhere else we
have to inspire people we have to give
them that sense of cause and vision that
their work is worth more uh we have to
make them feel like they matter and feel
like they're seen and heard and
understood and what ends up happening is
those people are not only more motivated
and inspired but if they're offered a
better higher paying job somewhere else
they turn it down because it's not just
about the bonuses and the money it's
because they would rather be here with
these wonderful people rule number nine
be ethical so ethical fading is a really
amazing and fascinating social
phenomenon
uh basically what it is is when a group
of people make unethical decisions
believing that they have are still
consistent with their own ethical
framework in other words they don't
think they've done anything unethical
right extreme examples of this would be
things like
um a pharmaceutical company raising the
price of an essential uh uh drug uh 500
800 a thousand percent five thousand
percent and though it may not be illegal
it's highly highly unethical
and and yet they don't think they've
done anything wrong
um uh that's an extreme example but we
see ethical fading happen all across
companies all the time
um where we do things that we know are
good for us where we might lie to our
our customers or our clients for example
or we might lie to each other to get
ourselves ahead you know this is all
these are all demonstrations of ethical
fading
um the way in which ethical fading
happens as you said one of the ways is
just a ridiculous unbalanced amount of
pressure on short term which forces us
to think about ourselves or or only
think about that short-term goal
um and then we can rationalize well
everyone's doing it it's what the
company wants me to do how else am I
going to get ahead I have to put food on
the table it's the system it's you know
like we can rationalize the behavior
um the also the slippery slope we do
something a little bit once it worked we
do it a little more it works we do a
little more it works and before you know
it you have full-blown ethical fading
and so the way you combat ethical fading
and and like I said I gave you an
extreme example of the Pharmaceuticals
but we see low-level ethical fading
across a lot of companies unfortunately
and the way you combat it is uh is one
uh uh good leadership uh where that kind
of thing is not tolerated so for example
it's it's totally normal for people to
have unethical ideas
um but the question is when when do they
get caught so in an unhealthy company
that that unethical idea is implemented
until social pressure or the law
intervenes or there's a scandal right
and then we say oh we're terribly sorry
we you know we're a very good company
after you got caught in a in a in a
properly ethical company somebody May
raise the idea in a meeting
and everybody in the meeting will go
that's funny but we would never do that
here
that's that's not us that's a little bit
unethical and we get it gets shut down
immediately
um and again that's good leadership
because it's the leaders who are
promoting people who are ethical who are
highlighting ethical behavior and acting
in a way that sets the tone and they're
not putting undue pressure on people to
break the rules in order to make the
numbers
um you know a lot of leaders
unfortunately when confronted with
toxicity or unethical Behavior they'll
shrug their shoulders and say I know but
the numbers are so good and they allow
it to happen and so one of the primary
ways in which you beat ethical fading
quite frankly is is good leadership but
the others are just cause you know
trusting teams all of these things
contribute to operating in a highly
ethical way and rule number ten the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is stay consistent so in the mid 1980s a
philosopher in Theologian by the name of
Dr James cars articulated these two
types of games finite games and infinite
games a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball
if there's a winner necessarily there
have to be losers and there's always a
beginning middle and an end right then
you have infinite games infinite games
are defined as known and unknown players
which means you don't necessarily know
who all the players are and new players
can join whenever they want
um uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out we're players in infinite
games every day of our lives right
there's no such thing as
um winning global politics there's no
such thing as winning marriage you can't
be number one in your marriage you can
be number two but you can't be number
one right
um uh there's no such thing as winning
education
nobody wins learning you can come in
first for the finite amount of time
you're at school where we agree upon the
time frame and the uh uh and the metrics
grades but nobody wins education and
nobody wins business like when Circuit
City went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders half the room doesn't know
what Circuit City is I know it's sort of
I realize that it used to be a company
that competed with Best Buy same thing
Big Box store went in bought a VCR you
don't know what a VCR is right
um
what I love about this these definitions
is that when we listen to the language
of so many leaders it becomes abundantly
clear that they don't know the game
they're playing in the number of leaders
who talk about being number one being
the best or beating their competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon metrics time frames or objectives
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win in a
game that has no finish line there's
some consistent and predictable outcomes
the big ones are the decline of trust
the decline of cooperation and the
client decline of innovation so let's
let's translate that to a policing
organization right an infinite game is
not the absence of finite games it is
the context within which finite games
exist clearly you are engaged in finite
things every day of your career you have
a project that you need to complete
there's a beginning middle and end if
someone has committed a crime you want
to try and catch that person there is a
known objective there's a beginning
middle and end there's going to be a
winner there's going to be a loser right
if somebody you're chasing somebody down
for for a moving violation for example
this is these things are finite but
policing and the organization of the
Orange County sheriff is an infinite
organization we hope that this
organization outlasts everybody here and
thrives Beyond everybody here so the
decisions we make and the way we conduct
ourselves have to be considerate of the
fact that we want this organization to
thrive for the long term
I had the opportunity to work with the
Navy Seals and within the Navy Seals
there's actually a more Elite group
within the Cs that's much harder to get
into you have to be a sealed for like
five years before you even can get into
this even more Elite group and I asked
the director of training for this group
you know how do you choose who gets into
this more Elite group within your own
within your own culture and he drew uh
an XY access he drew a a graph for me
um uh and on the vertical axis he wrote
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote trust the way they Define
performance is how good are you at your
job right your skill set uh the way they
Define trust is what kind of person are
you and the way they put it is I may
trust you with my money let me trust you
with my life but do I trust you with my
money and my wife's right so
so uh clearly nobody wants a low
performer of low trust clearly clearly
everybody wants the high performer of
high Trust on their team clearly they
learn is that a high performer of low
trust is actually a toxic team member
and they would rather have a medium
performer of high trust sometimes a low
performer of high trust it's a relative
scale over the high performer of low
trust and this is one of the highest
performing organizations on the planet
and they put huge uh Credence in the
trustworthiness and the character of the
team member over their simple uh
performance metrics in business we're
the opposite we have a million metrics
to measure someone's performance and we
have negligible to no metrics to measure
someone's trust and so you may have a
selfish driven toxic team member who if
they're high performing what do we do we
promote them and sometimes you get to
the point where leadership knows that
this person is toxic and you say you
know you probably should do something
about this you maybe want to remove them
from a team and they say the same thing
they're like yeah yeah I know
but the performance is so good
you're literally just waiting for
something to collapse meaning either
other people will leave or the culture
will start to crack or there's a scandal
or that person will leave because they
get a better job offer they're not loyal
so they may be your highest performer
but they're not loyal
um with the what the seals learn
uh is sometimes these these medium
performance of high trust are your best
natural uh uh best natural leaders the
irony is you know if you go to any team
it's actually really easy to find these
toxic team members that's the irony even
though we don't formally measure it go
to any team and ask them who the
is and they'll all point to the same
person okay
um uh and and and and that that's an
opportunity to coach them I don't
believe in firing them I believe in
coaching them you let people go when
they proved to be uncoachable and by the
way if you go to that same team you say
who do you trust more than anybody else
who's got your back no matter what who's
always who's always there to help you
they're probably also point to the same
person who might be your best natural
leader and they may not be your best
individual performer first and foremost
we have to understand that there's no
such thing as certainty of outcome and
this is why this is one of the this is a
huge difference between finite mindsets
and infinite mindsets right a
finite-minded leader is afraid of
surprises and does not like uncertainty
which is why they like to work work in
very short time frames because you can
actually affect quite a lot of certainty
if you only think quarter to quarter
maybe year to year but if you start
thinking in five and ten year increments
you we all know we have zero control
over those outcomes so finite minded
players like to play with very short
time frames because it makes them feel
better even though the game is infinite
so it's actually again sort of a stupid
idea
infinite minded players Embrace
uncertainty and find opportunity in
Surprise and so where something goes
wrong or different and just as an aside
I got such a kick out of when kovitz
struck you know everybody was talking
about during these uncertain times
newsflash all times are uncertain
there's never been a time in history
ever that was certain all that happened
was something that we didn't expect took
place that reminded us that time is
uncertain and for the finite-minded
players the immediate reaction was Panic
right
um what am I going to do how am I going
to survive and try and double down on
the old way of doing things hoping that
if I just did it more or at least
attempt to do it online that I would
that it would survive right the more
infinite minded players and this has
nothing to do with stress we can still
have high stress with the with with what
was going on but the more infinite
minded players saw the sudden change in
their business and saw and thought Oh
okay this is an opportunity what can I
do with this and instead of doubling
down on the way they used to do things
but doing it online they said okay the
times have changed the way I operate my
business have changed all the things
that I used to be able to do like having
lunch with people can't do anymore
so given what I know now if if I was
starting from scratch I have something
really valuable and important how would
I build my business today to still
provide the value to the people who are
looking for the thing that I offer
and that was their mentality their
mentality was very entrepreneurial their
mentality was very creative
um and they though it may have caused
stress there was an appreciation for the
opportunity listening is a trust
building exercise right if you've if
you're in a take it down to a personal
relationship if you've been if you've
ever had a romantic relationships a
loved one right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them but we attempt to hear
them make them feel heard doesn't mean
we have to agree but they have to feel
heard and you know the listening is not
hearing the words
you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's it
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening is that they
do and and by the way it's not 100
successful either you know because some
people are just hell-bent on and it and
but that's a minority
and so I think the exercises sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I wanna I wanna hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not there to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men
um uh
and I think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they're not
mutually exclusive
um I'll give you one one example
which is I have a friend who uh
refused to get vaccinated
and I sat down with her and I said
tell me tell me your reasoning
right she goes well
um this new technology like I don't
wanna we don't know it hasn't been out
long enough like we don't know so what I
hear is fear of the unknown
okay I go go on and she I let her talk
and say her thing and explain all the
things and I and then and I simply said
so you're afraid of the MRNA technology
right yes I don't want them screwing
with my DNA
I said well just so you know it's 20
year old technology but then I found
something I could agree with her but but
you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized you're absolutely right
that's the first time we've put it in
the market so I affirmed her fear
and then I said do you get flu shots
every year she goes I do I said okay
Johnson and Johnson is a good
old-fashioned flu shot it's a different
technology it's not mRNA so I you're 100
right if you're afraid of of the new
technology don't get modern or Pfizer
but Johnson and Johnson is it's just
like a flu shot it's the same old Tech
and she went it is and it is she went
and got a modern shot
[Laughter]
to be heard because most of her friends
when she said I'm not getting vaccinated
he yelled at her told her she was stupid
told her she's an idiot told her she's
letting her friends down told her she's
making other people sick told her she's
at risk to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all I did was let her feel heard
I think we do we can't we have to do
that find a friend you love and uh you
know one of those people who if you
called him at three o'clock in the
morning you know they'd take your call
and you would take theirs
um don't do this with a spouse don't do
this with a sibling uh uh don't do this
with a boyfriend or girlfriend those
relationships are too close
um but find a best friend and ask them
this simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy because it's very hard for
the human brain to put our feelings into
words because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings doesn't control
language this is why we use metaphors
and analogies and why we struggle to
tell people how we actually feel it's
because it's a different part of the
brain and so they're going to look at
you and be like uh
I don't know why are you asking me this
and you say come on I know you've been
there for me uh my whole life and then
you actually stop asking the question
why ironically you actually asked the
question what you say come on what
specifically is it about me that I know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
they're going to hem and hog because
it's hard to put into words don't help
them don't let anybody else help them
and they're going to start describing
you I don't know you're funny you're
smart you're honest you've always been
there for me you go good you play
Devil's Advocate good that's the
definition of a friend what it
specifically is about me that I'd know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
again some will get through this quickly
and some will get through it slowly and
it'll be a struggle and you have to
continue to play Devil's Advocate good
that's the definition of a close friend
what specifically is about me and
eventually they'll give up eventually
they'll stop describing you and they'll
start describing themselves like my
friend said to me Simon I don't know all
I know is that I can sit in a room with
you I don't even have to talk to you and
I feel inspired and I got goosebumps in
fact I'm getting them right now they
will put into words the value you have
in their life and you will have the
emotional reaction you'll either well up
with tears or you will get goosebumps
this puts you in the ballpark this is
where your why lives and if you do this
with multiple friends they will say the
same kind of thing in in fact sometimes
they'll say the same exact thing because
your why is the thing you give to the
world and amongst your closest and best
friends it is the space you fill in
their lives so that's a fun little way
you can find your why we don't teach
difficult conversations we don't teach
conflict resolution we don't teach
de-escalation uh and we don't teach how
to give and receive feedback we don't
teach how to treat ideas we don't even
teach people how to have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is is the skill
set that we that we can train
um the other thing is a lot of leaders I
think are afraid of doing things for
fear of saying the wrong thing and again
this this really lends itself to the
training we need to give our leaders and
especially I think this was really
exaggerated after the murder of George
Floyd
um where so many leaders did nothing
um they're not bad people uh they were
just so afraid of saying the wrong thing
or inflaming a situation or triggering
someone that they chose to to just do
nothing
um and so one of the things we need to
do is teach people how to lean into
tension
um uh and and to learn how to
de-escalate one's own anger or or one's
own trigger and again you brought it up
before which is and replace it with
curiosity tell me more what else I'm
struggling to under stand let me tell
you the story that's going through my
head I think is a really big one that
I've learned which is because I'm
reacting based on my own narrative right
and so they're reacting to my words or
my reaction and so one of the things
that's really helped me is to share
what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction is coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just telling you my
story and I'll say I had this happen in
the past where X Y and Z and so I'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where I'm coming from
and I think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so I think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um the worst thing the one that drives
me up the wall the one that triggers me
is this is how we've always done it well
why do we do it that way because this is
how we've always done it and my rule is
if you cannot tell me why we're doing it
this way that means it's it's on the
chopping block that doesn't mean it has
to change but but I wanna I want real
explanations of why we do something this
way if somebody can't tell me then then
then it's it's open to being changed
there's another guy who does what I do
he writes books he gives talks Etc his
work is extremely well respected and and
I admire his work as well
I happen to hate him
um he's never he's never done anything
mean to me and we've always had a very
quality relationship when we see each
other professionally I have an arbitrary
hatred of him
and as a result of my hatred I'm
extremely competitive with him
um I would log on to Amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind I checked no one else's
Just the Two of Us and if he was ahead I
was angry and if I was ahead I was smug
and whenever his name came up in polite
conversation I would see underneath
we were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together
um and I don't mean like like literally
we would be on the stage together and
the interviewer thought it would be fun
if we introduced each other
um
and so I went first
uh and I turned to him and I said
um you make me really insecure
and I said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses and whenever your name
comes up I get really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
think the same thing about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me because his
weakness is revealed to me because his
strengths revealed to me my weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say Here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
I say more fun to to direct all my
energies at beating him
um that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
um and I learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience I've never checked
mine or his book wrecking since
um I applaud his work celebrate him want
him to do well because it turns out
working together
we actually are stronger
um and I think this is the same Folly in
business right I I like you know which
is we decide who our competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like ABC NBC CBS and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at Nielsen radians every
morning
and then Netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all the reminders
because they weren't even looking they
weren't even watching because that's the
arbitrariness of if you I remember back
in the early days when I first started
my career I was in the ad business and I
was Junior dogs buddy to the junior
dog's body and
um I was on the
um competitive analysis team and
basically what that meant was we studied
the competition and we put together
decks to the executives of look what the
competition is doing
and we sometimes would hire outside
Consultants to run you know research for
us and if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so um
I think the value of the other players
in your industry of the other players in
the game is not to beat them because
there's no such thing as I said before
you know Best Buy didn't win anything
when Circuit City went bankrupt
um but it's to recognize and respect
them there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better design who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which could mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say okay let's make our
product even better they have revealed
our weakness let's Now work on that
because the ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself we don't
have to like our jobs every day but we
do get to love our jobs every days like
you don't like your children every day
but you love your children every day so
having a a hard day you know that that's
fine but the question is is what do we
fall in love with and at the end of the
day the reason
um uh that we Stay or Leave a job is
because how we feel about that job you
know I think we we misunderstand when we
think people just leave for money if
they just leave for money then they
never really had strong feelings at the
company in the first place right because
when people feel loyal to the company
they turn down jobs that offer them more
money or if it's so tempting and the
numbers are so high then they go to
their company and say listen I was
offered this job it's very tempting
there's a lot of pressure but I don't
want to lead is there anything you can
do to help me stay right so and you and
there's the point is is there they're
open about it and and what makes people
want to have that conversation like I
said is that they're seen and heard
um the best companies
um have all kinds of programs inside the
company to help the person grow as an
individual now we talked about you know
listening skills and these kinds of
things these are valuable for the work
that we do but it turns out that those
skills also help us as parents they help
us as as as spouses or as boyfriends and
his girlfriends these are valuable
skills in life
you know
um and I think that we forget that we
talk about hard skills and soft skills
as if those things are opposite it's a
terror I hate the term soft skills hard
skills and human skills and the more
that we invest in human skills in
addition to the hard skills that we're
teaching the more people feel like
they're growing as individuals I'm a
better version of myself now than I was
when I started at this company because
the company is actually helping me on a
in personal growth
um uh WD-40 which is a company that I
admire their their culture uh the
lubricant company
um uh they train their managers to be
coaches so literally like Executive
coaching training that kind of thing but
they train their own people to do to
have that skill set so that they're
equipped to help their people who have
challenges and especially with younger
generation you know the younger
generation is asking companies to
provide everything you know we want to
have our sense of belonging our sense of
community our sense of personal growth
our sense of purpose to come from work
work it didn't used to be like that 40
years ago
um and so and so there's a huge pressure
on companies and so I think what entices
people into the company and into the
industry is not just come and do cyber
security you know there's a percentage
of people who are you know de facto
interested in that but rather tell them
the kind of experience they're going to
have tell them what they get from the
company and you'll find it remarkable
how many people will all of a sudden be
interested in the in the category in the
company because of what they get
holistically not just what they get from
the product one of the things that um we
we do is um is is we is creating a
culture in which people understand that
the reason we're giving feedback is not
to quote unquote criticize them but to
help them grow as human beings
um and that has to be that has to be
established like this this is what we're
gonna the advice I I offer is it's not
just a checklist that you do and
everything goes fine you know you create
a culture in which uh difficult
conversations and uh and and critical
feedback are welcomed or at least
understood but it's also how we give it
usually we give it by pulling out a
piece of paper and pointing out the
thing that's wrong
um and you know and saying you've got to
fix something right we usually point to
the evidence first
um as opposed to starting by with by by
the human being which is you know
there's stuff I want to share with you I
don't know where what it means but I
wanted to raise it with you in case
there is an issue
um because I care about you and I want
to see that you grow here but there's
some evidence that things are going a
little sideways and I want to I want to
address them with them to see what
opportunities there are or if there's
anything wrong because I don't know the
reasons behind it but
um here's for example the way you talked
to your teammates the other day was a
little harsh and ordinarily I'd be one
to say oh you know you're having a bad
day it's no problem you know everybody
gets a everybody gets a bad day but
you've been really beating up on people
um I don't even know if you're aware of
that right
um and sometimes they say I'm having a
hard time and it opens up or they'll say
I wasn't even aware I didn't even know
or it reveals something as opposed to
saying stop yelling at people nobody
wants to work for you if all you do is
yell at people you know it's hard for
people to receive and so good feedback
is not just about conveying the point
we're trying to make it's about creating
a condition in which the person is more
likely to listen than hear it so we're
all proud of ourselves once we've told
them we did you did you give her the
feedback yeah I told her right did they
hear the feedback uh different question
one of the nice things about the
infinite game is two players or more who
sell basically the same product for
basically the same price for basically
the same quality can all be wildly
successful at the same time like no one
wins
um and and remember we're deciding the
metrics so we could decide that it's
market share or revenue or profit and
we're making these arbitrary comparisons
to arbitrary other players and we can be
all high and mighty about our ourselves
you know General Motors decided that um
that market share was the thing and they
were obsessed with being number one in
market share meanwhile they were losing
money hand over fist year after year
after year not sure if that's a very uh
infinite minded Focus uh because you're
clearly going to put yourself out of the
game remember when when Circuit City
went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything
um if anything they had to change the
way that they played because Amazon
became a much more dominant force in the
industry and so they couldn't actually
do the things that they used to do and
this is what it means to be an infinite
player means you understand that it's
not simply about repeating the same
thing that's always worked but it's
adapting with politics and culture and
technology and it's not actually about
competing against another player on in
the field but the only true competitor
in an infinite game is actually yourself
how do I make my product better this
year than it was last year how do I give
better advice this year than I gave last
year how to become a better leader this
year than I was than I was last year and
it's a constant constant education of
constant constant Improvement I can tell
you a funny story which uh you'll
recognize from the book which really
captures the difference between a finite
and infinite mindset and it comes from a
personal experience
I had the opportunity to speak at an
education Summit for Microsoft and then
a few months later I was asked to speak
in an education Summit for Apple now
this was back in the Steve Ballmer days
when Steve bummer men ran Microsoft
and at the Microsoft Summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple
Balmer at the time was obsessed with
beating Apple
um at the Apple Summit a hundred percent
of the executives spent a hundred
percent of their presentations talking
about how to help teachers teach and how
to help students learn one was obsessed
with their mission the other one was
obsessed with beating their competition
guess which one was struggling with
issues of trust cooperation and
innovation
um so at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing this was
Microsoft's response to the iPod
um and again there's plenty of uh
evidence and footage of Balmer talking
about he was going to beat the iPod and
this is going to be the best product
ever and I have to say this little piece
of technology was quite good it was very
user friendly it was it worked very well
it was it was it was a really nice
little product
um at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with a senior Apple
executive and I couldn't help myself I
happened I just had to stir the pot uh
so I I turned to him and I said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zune and it
is so much better than your iPod touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
because an infinite player understands
sometimes you have the better product
sometimes they have the better product
sometimes you're ahead and sometimes
you're behind uh the goal is not to beat
your competitor the goal is to outdo
yourself
where Microsoft was obsessed with
beating apple apple ignored Microsoft
and was obsessed with doing itself uh a
year later Apple introduced the iPhone
which rendered both the iPod and the
zoom completely obsolete I get asked
very often you know what are the most
important characteristics of leadership
Vision charisma uh you know I know
plenty of incredible leaders that aren't
Big Steve Jobs Visionaries you know
they're just not and I know some
fantastic leaders who do not have
Charisma they're quiet and super
introverted you know and they're just
not that exciting to talk to and spend
time with
um
uh
uh when I say Charisma I mean the
traditional definition yeah which is
more about energy I believe charisma's
undying belief in something and that
they have in Spades but I think courage
I think courage is the one thing that
all great leaders have to have because
we are surrounded by overwhelming forces
every day of Our Lives pushing us to
play the finite game you know if you're
a public company the the markets all
they want for their own selfish game is
for you to make short-term decisions the
pressures are overwhelming
um
if you're a numbers driven person the
pressures are overwhelming if you're in
survival mode the pressures are
overwhelming if you have a spouse who
spends more money than you can make the
pressures are overwhelming uh all the
pressures around us even the way we
treat competition versus rivalry like we
feel like we have to win win all the
pressures every day on us are absolutely
overwhelming for us to be finite and to
to prioritize the short term over the
long term to prioritize the Urgent over
the important and it takes unbelievable
courage to put the important before the
Urgent it takes unbelievable courage to
resist all the pressures coming from
selfish outside parties it comes it
takes unbelievable pressure to do the
right thing they happen to have a coffee
bar uh in the lobby of the Four Seasons
in Vegas and so one afternoon I went and
bought myself a cup of coffee and uh the
Barista working that day was a kid named
Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right clearly
it's clearly a different standard right
so when Noah said I love my job my ears
perked up
this kid has an emotional connection to
his work so immediately I followed up
and said tell me specifically what the
Four Seasons is doing that you would say
to me you love your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel
and there the managers walked past us
and catch us when we do something wrong
there the managers are always trying to
drive performance and make sure we hit
our numbers he said there I'd like to
keep my head below the radar get through
the day and just collect my paycheck
only at the Four Seasons do I feel I can
be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works you know I
get this question all the time you know
Simon how do we get the most out of our
people people are not a towel that you
ring them out to see how much you can
get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's
that's a good one man
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us unfortunately we also all know what
it feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement I
think one of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening and this is a skill that is
not taught in school we don't learn it
on Home unfortunately and and we don't
learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead I'm sorry
listening is
I thought I was being original
the the listening listening is not about
hearing the words that are spoken it's
not being able to Parrot back what
somebody said to you listening is
listening for meaning right
um you uh uh um you are a good listener
the test for being good listener is if
the other person feels heard
right say that again right write that
down so so I mean we've all had we just
take it out of the context of business
right we've all had an argument or
wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can I just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened and what they're
missing is you are not looking for them
you're not looking for them to compare
the facts of what's being said you just
want to feel heard you just want
somebody to go oh my God that's really
hard yeah I hear it I hear that thank
you for sharing that with me that must
be difficult
that's all I needed right I'll give you
a a a a very funny example of bad
listening so I used to date a girl who's
an air traffic controller air attractive
controllers are breed unto themselves
and it's only about the facts and I woke
up one morning I had something in my eye
and I couldn't open my eye it was
hurting and I'm like flushing it out
with water and nothing's work and I mean
I couldn't even open my eyes to have her
come on like come here come here I'm
gonna look in my eye what did you see
anything do you understand anything and
she looks in she goes like this and she
goes there's nothing there and then
walks away
and I eventually you know whatever it
was I eventually was okay and I went up
to her I was like
WTF right
I'm like I had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
I was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not going to get anything
out of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
I'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my God that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and if somebody can learn to listen and
now now this is where it gets actionable
this is not me just waxing philosophical
and telling funny stories about
listening my friend will gudero do how
many of you are
or restaurant people have you ever heard
of 11 Madison Park so at some point in
New York City 11 Madison Park was the
best rest restaurant in the world right
ranked number one and will believes in
this he's he was the former owner he
believes in this concept of unreasonable
Hospitality which is going to what good
services and then going Way Way Beyond
and one of the core tenets of
unreasonable hospitality is learning to
listen and I'll give you an example that
directly impacts your business most
agents don't listen
and I'll give you an example what do you
do what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all we've we've all bought
a home too right which is you walk into
this new home that you just bought as a
buyer and there's a bottle of champagne
in the fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic I'm a number
it's just it's just rote but if you were
listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little Nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked and goes I could make this
my yoga room and that's the house they
bought instead of putting a bottle of
champagne in the house this is what will
talks about instead of putting a bottle
of champagne in the fridge why not put a
yoga mat in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect right
that's called listening and every single
time you go out
every single time you go out with
clients
uh
they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big Windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning and that's
those the little notes you want to make
that make someone feel seen and make
someone feel heard how can we ensure
that we're changing with times
technology culture politics and tastes
um rather than just trying to beat our
competitor and you see it across
Industries uh you know uh publishing for
example
um you know the internet showed up and
they they saw it and they thought it was
nice and they you know as it took on
they sort of I guess they were
interested in it they sort of played
defense and then Amazon showed up and
Amazon went to all of them and said hey
you want to invest in us and they all
said no well now they're all playing
catch up they're all playing defense you
know Netflix went to Blockbuster and
said want to buy us and Blockbuster said
know the rest of the TV and movie
industry were too busy comparing who had
higher ratings and they completely
missed the fact that Netflix is now
completely reinvented television I find
that fascinating General Motors was
destroying its own electric vehicles in
a in a to protect its old business and
now they're all rushing to catch up with
Tesla I think this is hilarious and it's
the little companies the Netflix is the
Amazons the Teslas that get ignored that
aren't seen as a threat that end up
defining and redefining entire
marketplaces now this is not unique to
small companies big companies can
absolutely redefine the problem is big
companies are more obsessed with their
finite goals big companies are more
obsessed with beating their competitors
and little companies are obsessed with
their Vision little companies are
obsessed with this outsized Vision that
outstrips the resources they have right
somebody says we're going to do this and
everybody looks around and goes we don't
have the money for that we don't have
the talent for that I guess we'll have
to be creative
and I think this is one of the
opportunities for big companies as they
get big their Visions get smaller they
become goals that they can just do a
back plan for there's nothing inherent
that a big company shouldn't be
Innovative but to your point before they
become risk-averse they become stable
um and at the end of the day it takes
huge Vision what I imagine is a huge
corporation a multi-billion dollar
corporation that someone will say we
imagine a world that's so crazy and so
idealistic that in this large
corporation they all look around and go
we don't have the money for that
we don't have the talent for that I
guess we'll have to be creative
which scares the heck out of
um uh the investor Community but
remember all of those companies were
founded by you know whether it's your
Steve Jobs or all of all these companies
Salesforce they all started by young
people who had no experience and only
had Vision
um and I think that's there's no reason
why big companies cannot uh cannot be
Innovative but I think
it's about pushing their own boundaries
and allowing for entrepreneurship and
inherent in entrepreneurship is
failure you can't experiment without
failing I remember talking to a CFO of a
big company once and he told me that he
has two priorities for the company uh uh
uh Innovation and efficiency
I I said good luck with that you know
there's nothing efficient about
Innovation because you have to keep
trying something over and over again
there's nothing efficient about that and
for some reason I don't know what it is
companies are obsessed with growth
and everybody they brag we're a hyper
Growth Company show me one article not
10 not 15 show me one article that shows
any data that hyper growth is good for
business and good for the company
there is no data to show that companies
are obsessed with growth actually build
stronger companies because they don't
um and so it is a Fool's errand that is
promoted usually by an incentive
structure that rewards short-term
benefits I think what companies can do
is start to look at their incentive
structures and start rewarding things
like teamwork ethics and and long-term
gain and guess what you'll get the
behavior year reward there's no such
thing as a perfect job and there's no
such thing as a perfect person of course
there are things that we are doing that
hold ourselves back and of course there
are things about the environment in
which we work whether it's the people or
the job or the whatever the
circumstances that may also be holding
us back I mean but to see ourselves as
victims is not is not the up is not the
thing but rather to seek opportunity and
it goes back to that growth mindset
um uh which is it's what I've learned is
one of the best ways to grow oneself is
to actually help somebody on the team
grow service you know there's an entire
section in the Bookshop called self-help
and there's no section of the Bookshop
called help others and I think what
we've done is we've over indexed on the
whole rugged individualism sort of
self-help anything how can I be
successful how can I grow my business
how can I lose weight how can I find
love and yet we forget how can I help
somebody else grow their business how
can I help somebody else find success
how can I help help somebody else lose
weight and find love
Etc and the irony is is the more that we
set out to help somebody else because we
have more objectivity with other people
ironically we actually learn to help
ourselves I I tried this out I did a
little experiment
um a dear friend of mine was going
through a hard a hard time
a solopreneur
um
the work wasn't going well her marriage
was shaky and she was in a bad place
and so she knows what I do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me he said of
course so every single week religiously
we spent about 90 minutes together she'd
come over and we would talk and I would
offer some
perspective and some ideas and she'd
feel great for like a day or two and
then she'd go back and we'd get together
the next week and she'd feel great for a
couple of days and then go back in this
repeating pattern went on for quite a
while
and then I remembered my own work which
is the idea of service
and had a little idea which is to switch
to switch it around and I called her up
and said look I would like some coaching
too and it was genuine I said you know
me better than anybody else I trust you
completely when we get together for one
of our sessions Can it can I can I use
up some of the time can I tell you what
I'm going through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes talking about my stuff
and this went week after week after week
where she was just the uh advice giver
and strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me that she was gaining
all the insights and perspective because
it wasn't personalized it's like sales
training and anybody who's ever gone
through sales training you know this
which is you always do it with three
people you know the person who plays the
role of the salesperson the person who
plays the role of the uh the person
you're selling to the buyer and an
observer and it's the Observer that does
the learning not the people playing the
roles well in this case you got to see
herself not being not be uh so close to
it gave her objectivity so I'm a great
believer in if you have a problem to
solve it work try and help somebody else
solve that same problem
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Gary vaynerchuk
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the process of
doing something you actually like is my
great addiction the fact that I am able
to actually wake up day in and day out
sleep easily for seven eight hours a
night and wake up